Rock late 90s few cycles of droids at
the University of Miami moving into
wrestling kind of puffy defensive
lineman body not shredded Rock yet side
titty Rock
that's that's the good [__] right there
I love to just go Peppa pepp oh yeah
punch me right in the [__] face and
knock me into next week bloody wood oh
man I would love that I would [__]
feel baby that [__] chest feel that
side yeah that side view and then he
just and then I just wake up my teeth
are gone and just taste the iron of my
own blood in my mouth and go the rock
[__] the rock is me in the face
yeah dude I was there when the rock came
back dude what do you mean I went to one
SummerSlam in my whole life or whatever
it was and it was the one where the rock
came back dude and it was did the roof
blow off the [__] joint I'll I
remember like it was yesterday man the
music came on and I didn't know really
what was going on you know I had I kind
of bowed out of wrestling kind of
whenever uh the big boss man died okay
you know yeah next thing you know there
was this Mexican father and son right
and the son was probably six years old
and the dad was maybe 35.
and they
were the same height okay and they were
both wearing
The Rock belts right and they just
started bawling crying together at the
same time dude it's and he came out dude
it's a religious experience it was
Unreal he's the best person on the
planet I've always said I mean I've been
saying and I'm not alone in this he's
the best person in the planet run the
rock third party might have a chance I
don't think that he I think that he
would get pilfer from both you know from
the the yeah the Dems and the GOP I
think that he's the only person who
could do that Tom Hanks couldn't do that
Miley Cyrus couldn't do that but um
Tom Hanks I think he just beloved enough
he's beloved enough but then you know
there's there's uh there are some people
who are like he eats babies yeah so
there's enough people that are like he
eats babies no he doesn't yes so that's
gonna that'll affect your ability to get
into office but the Rock
he's the best human being in the [__]
world yeah he's big he's powerful he
definitely he's kind of you can't tell
if he's like Mexican or black or or kind
of like off-white or semi-white or gloss
or matte he's gonna be yeah he's
definitely not gloss or Matt he's like a
he's like a tablet that you can read
books on yes it's not shiny or one of
those like frames that you get for your
your parents where they can where it's
like oh new pictures show up and you
just upload them and it doesn't look
like a screen well you know what he is
he's if you put in a do if you put into
AI hey give me the best person yeah a
man that you could make yeah you'd get
that guy and and he's also that's right
that's what all Americans will look like
if we last a thousand years oh we're
beige power dude nobody realizes that we
were four generations away from
everybody being babes yes that's why
it's like even when I like
four generations from everyone being
based oh dude it's like you can't even
be racist now without a chart I feel
like you have to be able to like
carry the one you gotta sure yeah I
missed the old days you'd be like hey
yeah yeah
you're right uh Chinese yeah you are
Chinese or you are Japanese
you are a South Asian Indian person now
it's like what a German Indian with also
American Indian in them I know oh yeah
no black Alzheimer's dude well we were
lit you know we but we were raised in
South America because my grandma's
Argentina well how did that happen well
she and then you know the Indian
somebody came on a boat yes it was
horrible
this it's all unrealness so it's like
yes I just missed the old days when it
was like this is who did it officer yeah
and he was black now you gotta like have
all these other oh man possibilities
yeah yeah yeah yeah uh gee whiz but it's
definitely I think we are like you're
saying we're all headed to be in beige
the rock is the perfect AI male no doubt
um yeah shredded 50 years old and can
whoop anyone's [__] head uh oh and he
looks like he could blow a dude just
with his uh with like uh he could wink
on your dick and you'd come yeah he's
yeah he's a beautiful man and everyone
can agree on it and woman too some you
know sure with a lot of these new women
I think a lot of women look at him and
be like I can do it you know yeah he
yeah if he decided to be like you know
to go into like the Winter Olympics and
on the women's luge team or something oh
that would be that would be awesome skip
the whole power lifting thing you know
just find some like find a specific
sport he could be like the new X Games
like women's champ riding a Imagine The
Rock riding a BMX bike doing 360s and
[__] in the air
that would be crazy I actually that's
when they almost can't imagine him doing
that's the one thing yeah until AI can
be an audience for AI and we're just
extinct and it's just computers it just
I don't even understand why you would
need a planet
at that point we're going to need humans
until that point yeah I mean whatever we
rule right I mean we make soup out of
sharks and [__] yeah we do whatever the
[__] we want oh yeah until dogs get
super smart like in that Rick and Morty
episode uh it's still going to be us I
think we're still the Champs it's uh
there's not gonna be a whole lot of so
long as the rock is around yeah yeah
there's if there's someone who can [__]
up AI it's the rock yeah I always say
pour water on it just if we don't like
AI very simple pour water on it
um uh but the rock could actually that
would be like a good a great comeback
and wrestling fans are always they
thought it was going to happen this year
with The Rock versus his uh actual uh
cousin of of sorts they're related in
some way Roman Reigns who is the
universal and World Heavyweight Champion
right now uh people thought The Rock was
going to come back if somehow Vince
McMahon and Triple H and Stephanie
McMahon could put together The Rock
versus AI yeah that would be a good one
and my money's on the Rock even though
the outcomes are predetermined yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one